The total mechanical
energy, E sub mech
is defined as the sum
of the kinetic energy
and the potential
energy, so the sum
of K plus U, where U is the
potential energy function
associated with the
conservative force--
with an appropriate
choice of zero point.
If there are multiple
conservative forces acting
on the system, then
U will be the sum
of individual potential
energy functions
for each conservative force with
an appropriate choice of zero
point for each
individual function.
We've also seen that the
change in the kinetic energy
plus the change in
the potential energy
is equal to the change in
the total mechanical energy.
And that's just basically the
derivative of the equation
that I wrote above.
And this change in the
total mechanical energy
will be 0 for
conservative forces.
In addition, we've seen that
the change in potential energy
is related to the conservative
work done in the system
so that W sub C, the
conservative work done,
is equal to the negative of the
change in the potential energy.
But we also know that
the total work done
includes both conservative
and non-conservative forces.
So the total work done is
equal to the sum of W sub C,
the conservative work done, plus
the non-conservative work done,
and that that total work
is equal to the change
in kinetic energy.
Now, I can rewrite that
equation by rewriting
the conservative work in
terms of the potential energy.
So I could write this, now,
as the non-conservative work
minus the change in
the potential energy
is equal to the change
in the kinetic energy.
This is, again, just a
restatement of the work
kinetic energy theorem.
Now, by rearranging
this equation,
this means that the
non-conservative work is equal
to delta K, the change
in kinetic energy,
plus delta U, the change
of potential energy.
But that's equal to the change
in the total mechanical energy.
So the non-conservative
work is equal to the change
in the total mechanical energy.
This is a sufficiently
important result
that I'm going to write
it by itself in a box.
So the non-conservative
work is equal to the change
in the total mechanical energy.
So what we've shown
here is that the result
of any non-conservative
work on the system
is to change the total
mechanical energy
of the system.
Now, if there is no
non-conservative work,
if the forces acting on the
system are all conservative,
then the total mechanical
energy remains unchanged
now that Emech is 0.
And we say to the total
mechanical energy is conserved.
Now if there is a
non-conservative force,
it turns out that in
most cases the work done
by non-conservative
force is negative,
resulting in a
negative change in
the total mechanical
energy-- in other words,
in the removal of
total mechanical energy
from the system.
It's lost from the system.
Now we've been talking here only
about mechanical energy, which
we've defined as the
sum of kinetic energy
and potential energy.
But one can also talk about
non mechanical energy.
The most common example of which
is loosely referred to as heat.
As an example, in
the case of friction,
which is a
non-conservative force,
we know that the action of
friction generates heat.
What's happening is that the
non-conservative work done
by friction is negative
and, therefore, is reducing
the mechanical energy, the
total mechanical energy,
according to this expression,
but where does that energy go?
We said that it's removed
from the system-- in terms
of mechanical
energy, that's true.
But we can think of it
as, at the same time,
causing an increase in the non
mechanical energy, or the heat
energy, of the system.
So if one were to keep
track of both mechanical and
non-mechanical energy,
then it turns out
that the total energy,
mechanical and non-mechanical,
the total energy of a
system is conserved,
even if non-conservative
forces are acting.
However, it's
difficult to recover
the non-mechanical
energy and change it back
into mechanical energy.
These non-conservative
processes are not reversible.
This is a complicated
topic, and it's
the province of more advanced
courses in thermodynamics
or statistical mechanics,
which you may encounter later.
In this course, we will
confine our attention
to mechanical energy,
the sum of kinetic energy
and potential energy, and will
treat non-conservative force
as removing, or adding,
mechanical energy
to the system.